ich glaube ist es mal wieder an der zeit
für eine challenge und gemeinsam mit
kennwort habe ich mir überlegt im zuge
der kennwort can challenge dass ich euch
also meine komödie die frage welche
herausforderungen ihr vielleicht habt
als idee was ich als nächstes backen
oder kochen könnte
also macht gerne million euro in die
kommentare vielleicht kennt ihr was
kompliziert ist wo auch ich so ein
bisschen ins verzweifeln vielleicht
komme ich traue mich da gerne dran und
ich habe mir überlegt schreibt die
kommentare einfach hier drunter und das
video und der kommentar der dann
aufgesucht wird der bekommt ein schönes
überraschungspaket ich bin schon
gespannt darauf freue mich auf die
challenge lasst euch was einfallen und
ich glaub ich kriege jetzt schon ein
bisschen ja
probiere es einfach macht einfach und
ich stelle mit jeder herausforderung
ich bin bei allem dabei
das sage ich jetzt so einfach aber dann
macht es einfach